yes we get so many questions about
openings in our broadcast and for me the
starting point is often should I get
better at this opening that I'm
struggling with or should I chuck it and
start a new one exactly how do you
decide Wow it's so tough and it's so
individualistic right because an opening
that might have brought you amazing
number of victories when you are
starting stops it just stops delivering
the guts and then you have to change and
as you evolve as a player do you start
playing openings that are super double
risky or even less risky and this is so
individualistic so for me Jennifer
opening choices are really really really
hard I am not joking they're so
difficult in fact I suggest professional
advice really I love the idea of going
to coach and saying look this is what I
want I want a repertoire that does these
things for me like for example let's say
you're a gambler you really love those
risky double-edge variations well that's
I give me I'm gonna suggest all kinds of
dragon Sicilians like a play Grune
Feld's your favorite young lady
Greenfeld plays Kings Indians super
sharp dynamic where the game can change
instantly I'm more of a player
I like the strategic the slow play the
build-up to the battle so I like playing
from a position of safety and then
taking more more and more space and just
destroying you slowly so I like to play
openings that match my style and when
I'm forced by the circumstance of a
tournament I have to play for a win is
black that's tough that's out of my
comfort zone so I have to develop
weapons for those individual moments and
it's really really hard and that's why I
suggest coaching that's right it is very
difficult but are there any openings
that stand out
you mean before this video of course as
being underrated particularly let's
let's say defenses to 1d for openings
that don't get as much love as they
deserve
exactly okay so first of all regardless
of your strength of player starting play
or class player getting experts becoming
really good master player and about you
must you must study the classical
defenses d4 d5 c4 c6 that's a Slav study
up you have to have a classical defense
in your repertoire for both efore and d4
so double King pawn as well absolutely
at least study the so that you can
understand why does G 45 c4 c6 not just
work swimmingly I just developed my
knight to Essex and move my Bishop to f5
and life is wonderful right like if you
could just do all of those things then
King zillion Grunfeld Queen's Indian
wouldn't exist exactly exactly
so you but this is a kind of an
evolutionary type of understanding so
you have to start with something very
very classical now I grew up in
Americans wisss basically what that
meant was if I wasn't scoring 90% I
wasn't wearing winning my class prize or
I wasn't winning the tournament and it
was all about scoring five and a half
out of six or even sometimes six out of
six so that meant you had to win with
white and when with black and a defense
like for me the Banco gambit was a
defense that was a really really good an
underrated defense I think a lot of
people who played the Banco gambit were
surprised how they got such easy
positions like the white player was just
very satisfied just to be a pawn up and
think oh just because I'm a pawn up I'm
gonna win because I'm up material and
it's not a position where the pawn makes
that big a difference it's really about
the maneuvering and the quality of the
harmony of the pieces so for me if I if
I had a
a young player that was coming up today
I would be saying look let me teach it
about the Bangko can but it's really
underrated even today a good pic and I
think Alejandra would like what you're
saying oh yeah I'm sure he does we can't
because it's a huge conversation to do
it okay there's two big aspects here a
is picking your openings right sure that
you pick ones that fit your style and
that aren't too dubious but then the
second step is actually knowing enough
about this opening so that you can
improve your rating right obviously
you're not gonna be an 1800 knows it to
a 2800 level right but so that you can
kind of make your openings a good part
of your game not a lacking part of your
game it's so what are your main tips go
to chess space write out the ideas
behind your openings what should the
program look like exactly so for me
especially I really believe in the easy
steps okay I want to guide I don't want
to be the guy who say okay I've come to
a fork in the road do I take the left or
the right no I want to say I've got this
professional his name is Gary Kasparov
and he plays the groom fell defense so I
have this Gaiden I'm gonna use him he's
the guy he's the guy who's paid 2,000
hours per year studying this opening the
defense I'm going to choose my
repertoire based on how he plays so I'm
saying make that shortcut find yourself
a guide a professional player who's
really good at a specific opening and
let him guide you in your chess opening
and understanding and if you can't
afford Garry Kasparov or well no I mean
I'm saying you down the chess base and
the databases oh oh you're saying follow
I think you may be getting your coach no
follow a great player and kind of copy
what's up very so Peter Svidler who by
the way big shout out to Peter he's a
great groom felt the defense player
start with NBL what does MBL do against
this approach of the groom felt what
does he do against that approach follow
MBL don't sit there and say Oh
I'm going to out out think MVL and his
approach to this particular position no
it's not going to happen I have a copy
yet for that like please sometimes you
follow people and if you're not at that
level there are lots of some variations
and you're not gonna understand why they
chose X Y or Z right so that's why it's
so agreed to have a coach but if you
can't afford a coach I would say the
next best thing is have a training
partner to break down the more obvious
questions that you'll never get in the
annotations to MBL's game because he's
gonna be talking a very high level
usually in the post-mortem analysis is
and whatnot so that you can ask just the
more like ball well like why you work be
one instead of Bishop e2 it's like just
the things that are so obvious to the
high level but might not be obvious to
you you talk to that with your coach or
with your training partner and that'll
help you understand the opening a lot
better which basically will help
remember it oh I couldn't agree with you
more and furthermore I'd really like the
idea of taking your own little note
notebook and writing out the variations
in the key moments and to this extent
one of my great pleasures in the world
of chess is the friendships that I've
developed through chess and if you've
got a friend who's a good competitor and
a rival and you cannot buck heads
together and study together
that's just a great way of improving
your game job so make friends and pick
the right openings to start with the
formula to success